oh my god are you kidding me i don't
know if it's because we're gay or
because we're interracial you go girl
you take that black guy off the market
hi i'm cheryl and i'm hispanic hi i'm
alvin
and i'm black hi i'm merle and i'm arya
we've been dating for
a year and three quarters hi i'm jeremy
i'm white hi i'm mithala i'm south asian
hi my name is richmond and i'm asian hi
my name is mark and i'm white
never have i ever fantasized about
having biracial babies
yeah yeah i don't know the science of
how it works but i feel like
definitely wish we could mix some of our
jeans into a baby
i think it would be like the most
beautiful baby i have i mean just
through the nature of having dated you
for this long and i've thought about
what our children would look like
sometimes no kind of wondered about
it and also kind of wondered about what
kind of conversation we'd have to have
with them
let me explain obviously my kids are not
gonna come out
fully black maybe the kids don't be
light-skinned maybe the kid's gonna be
dark-skinned maybe they think he's gonna
have curly hair
the kid's gonna have straight hair maybe
the kid is gonna have wavy hair i don't
think anybody who
is about to get married to somebody or
is married to somebody
and doesn't have kids doesn't fantasize
about the kids that they're
going to have never have i ever dated
outside of my race before this
relationship
oh i i think i knew that i knew that
though yes i popped that cherry
i grew up in a very very white place in
massachusetts
you're the first person i dated really
so yeah i
didn't really date anyone before you i
grew up in mostly rural small town
georgia so
didn't have a lot of diversity mostly
just hit enough other
white people i have not i have where i
grew up which was in florida for the
most part it's kind of like a melting
pot
never have i ever felt stared at when
i'm in public
with my partner we were sitting in a
food court
and there's like this group of latino
men who just kind of like
stared at you and stared at me they
definitely didn't seem too
happy i feel like sometimes it's like oh
my gosh you brought him to
eat
and so they look at us like oh my god
that's so cool that
you brought him to experience our
culture yeah that's not surprising
it's not i feel like when people stare
at us in public i don't know if it's
because we're gay or because we're
interracial
i think it's a little bit of both yes i
get stared at around like where his
family's from
in rural georgia because i'm kind of the
only person who
looks like me about that going to india
with her family
i did get stared at a couple of times
because you know not a lot of
people walking around especially with
another indian family oh my god
are you kidding me i mean i get stared
at because you know what okay now
you're so good looking i'm so good
looking we're gonna get looked at also
because i'm taller than arya
i don't feel the stairs as much never
have i ever had a family member
disapprove
for dating outside my race i have
if you're darker skinned latino you're
not
seen as high in society so
when they see us stay outside of our
race and
it's a person who's darker than us they
see it as like
not bettering the race which is really
really bad
now they love you they cook for you
before they cook for me
for the most part my family just cares
about dating someone who's compassionate
honest kind my dad would be like 100
approved and my mom would like observe
him
and be like hmm you're at 88 approval
today or
95 approval today it was more about how
much approval
never have i ever felt overwhelmed by a
language barrier
oh really like when your family visited
sometimes i like don't fully get what
your mom
is saying i don't know if that's because
of the tagalog or just because
she speaks very fast mark does know one
sentence in tagalog thank you rosetta
stone
i've had a couple of times where i've
been overwhelmed just because i think
everybody switches
contacts between languages and they
don't realize it and since i only
understand english details they get lost
kind of get lost for me
we went in india like after we got
engaged we were all like
getting ready and then uh we were
telling jeremy oh there's like a dinner
party we have to go to i was
kind of confused about how to dress for
the dinner party and then my dad
was like oh someone tell him to change
later on i realized it was an engagement
party and i was just like okay this is
the context that i was kind of missing
during the conversations oh you haven't
i have because sometimes your parents
speaking curl
and it's like when i'm doing something
in the kitchen and then i'll ask you i'm
like hey what are they saying and you're
like
definitely not never have i ever been
praised for being in an interracial
relationship
really yeah i've definitely heard people
be like oh that's so cool
that like you're dating a white guy yeah
but also just like oh like that you're
an
interracial couple i have yeah which i
don't
necessarily think you know we would hope
to hopefully be at a baseline where it
doesn't need to be praised where's the
norm
who praised you the internet
[Laughter]
i did have a friend say that
she thought it was like trendy it is
inappropriate so i had to
like make a point to tell her that which
was an awkward conversation but it's
not necessarily what we need to be
having did you tell her you get your
hands
no i did next time i don't think i've
had anybody who just like
openly was like oh my gosh i am so happy
that you're dating me
wow like were they're like you go girl
you take that black guy off the market
no never have i ever had a hard time
understanding my partner's point of view
sometimes
like small things like there's also been
like what's comfort food for me when i'm
sick is not comfort food for him and
he's like we have to kind of like talk
about it and explain where we're coming
from i don't know if this is applicable
to all southeast asian cultures but i
know laos thailand
you know the feet are considered well
literally they're the bottom of the
of the body right there the dirtiest
part of the body and the head is the
most sacred
and so you never you know you grew up
never wanting to point your feet at
someone's face or
it being above their head like in
thailand do not put your feet up on the
table i had to educate merle as to why
you know like i would prefer
if she doesn't you know raise her feet
above my head oh yeah i was lying on the
couch yes
and like arya's head will be there and
my hip will be here and i she likes to
put her feet up here so it's at the
level of my head so of course she's not
trying to disrespect me but then i
explained to her for a little while i
got like even a little frustrated
because i was like i'm so
natural like i naturally just had never
thought about where my feet are
i think i was being more defensive
though because i was like wow you really
think i want to like
i'm trying to disrespect you or
something never have i
ever had to overcome religious
differences with my partner
we actually ended up having two
different weddings uh one in america one
in india for my family
the one in america we didn't get married
in the church but we had like both our
moms do readings from
both the different religions the wedding
in india we had like a hindu ceremony or
both our families fully participated
i have i have when i first started damn
you you were
catholic and i remember we wanted to go
to church together
she was like yeah you should go to the
church that i go to you were the second
black
person to come you walked in and it was
like
there's a spotlight on you're like yeah
everyone started scared
my experience was we went to a black
church
we were also like in this position where
we were looking for a new church
that we both felt comfortable at but
then i felt like everyone was staring at
me
and i felt like uncomfortable because
when i wasn't raised like
raising your hands or like really
feeling the holy spirit which is
beautiful
but i just wasn't comfortable what do
you appreciate about your partner the
most
he just loves me for who i am
how supportive richmond is
i'm more like do things and then
consider and you are not and so it's
like really good to have that in my life
like to balance it out i'm also very
grateful for her perspective
i am most grateful for his
open-mindedness
and appreciation for my culture what i
am grateful about with my partner is how
intentional she is and i'm just glad
that i have that in mind
[Music]
you